- [Lex] Can you just touch
on the topic of simulation?
Do you find this thought
experiment that we're living
in a simulation useful,
inspiring or constructive
in any kind of way?
Do you think it's ridiculous?
Do you think it could be true?
Or is it just a useful thought experiment?
- I think it is extremely
useful as a thought experiment
because it makes sense to everyone,
especially as we see virtual
reality and computer games
getting more and more complex.
You're not talking to an
audience in Newton's time
where you're like "Imagine a
clock that it has mechanics
"in it that are so complex
that it can create love."
And everyone's like "Mmmm, no."
(interviewer laughing)
But today you really start to feel, man,
at point is this little
robot friend of mine
gonna be like someone I don't
want to cancel plans with.
(laughs)
And so it's a great,
the thought experiment
of do we live in a simulation,
am a a brain in a vat
that has just been given
electrical impulses
from some nefarious other
beings so that I believe
that I live on earth and that
I have a body and all of this.
And the fact that you
can't prove it either way
is a fantastic way to introduce people
to some of the deepest questions.